the following is a conversation with yon
mi park
a north korean defector human rights
activist
and author of the book in order to live
quick mention of our sponsors balcampo
gala games
better help and ate sleep check them out
in the description
to support this podcast let me say a few
words about north korea
from 1994 to 98 north korea went through
a famine
mass starvation caused primarily by king
jong-il
who at the time was the new leader of
north korea
after his father's death in 1994
somewhere between
600 000 and 3 million people
died due to starvation from all the
stories of famine in history
including my own family history i've
come to understand
that hunger tortures the human mind
in a way that can break everything we
stand for in north korea
during the 90s famine many were driven
to cannibalism
imagine more than 10 million people
suffering starvation for months
and years always on the brink of death
we don't know the exact numbers of
people who died because the suffering
was done in silence
in darkness very little information in
or out most people had to survive
without electricity
without clean water medical supplies
sanitation
and food the north korean propaganda
machine called this
the arduous march or the march of
suffering
and words such as famine and hunger were
banned because they implied government
failure
and once again now in 2021
kim jong-un the current leader of north
korea is calling for his country to
prepare for another arduous march
or march of suffering another period of
mass starvation
as the country closes its borders
looking
at atrocities of the past decades and
the encroaching atrocity there now
i think about the quiet suffering of
millions of north koreans
i think about the torture of the human
spirit
i think about a north korean child who
could be a scientist
an artist a writer but who instead grows
impossibly thin
without food their bodies slowly rotting
away as their parents watch helplessly
i got emotional in this conversation
with you on me
in part because i remembered my
grandmother who survived khaldamur
the famine in ukraine intentionally
created by stalin
where 4 to 10 million people died and
many
many more suffered imagine knowing that
if you don't engage in cannibalism
you will die before your children did
and then
they will be eaten imagine because of
this
deciding to murder and eat your own
children as many people did
imagine the kind of desperation torture
that leads up to a decision like that
i'm not smart enough to know what evil
is
know where to draw the line between good
and evil
but stalin king jong-il kim jong-un
are men who are in the name of power are
willing to make
millions of people of children suffer
and die from starvation
i rarely have hate in my heart but i
hate these men
i hate that such men exist in this world
i hate
that the beauty i love about this life
exists
amidst such unimaginable cruelty
i have been haunted by this conversation
by memories of my grandmother's pain
but i've also been warmed by memories of
her love
love gives me hope hope for the
perseverance of the human spirit
even in the face of evil
this is the lex friedman podcast and
here is my conversation
with yomi park can you tell your story
from north korea to today as you
describe in your 2015 book
and with the extra perspective on life
love and freedom you've gained since
then
wow that's a long story so i was born in
the northern part of north korea
initially
and my father was a party member
and my mom was housewife i had a one
order sister
and i remember born in that country i
never thought i was
in an unusual country now i'm thinking
of what it is like
literally called the hermit kingdom but
i thought
i believed that i was living in the best
country on earth
it was a socialist paradise and
everybody
in the rest of the world worshipped my
idea leader
and there was nothing to envy for me
so i had this enormous pride in my heart
and grateful to be in that country so
was love for the leader not
fear for me at least it was love
yeah it was all the moderation and
gratitude
it changed lately but for me was pure
pure like love was there any
like looking back with the perspective
you have now
would you describe some of those moments
growing up
as full of happiness or was that
delusion at the time so not knowing the
alternative
will you still be able to be happy the
fact that i did not know
like in north korea this is the only
country in this 21st century has no
internet
and they don't even know the existence
of internet
not only that we don't even have this 20
like like
you know 24-hour electricity yeah so not
knowing
definitely helped i think to be sane
so as a human being you're still able to
find moments of happiness
i think my happiness was from family
nothing else even though those they was
keep telling me that they were
our source of meaning and happiness i
don't think i ever got
happy by that maybe they're here and
they're in schools and like when i was
learning propaganda
like you know the proud feeling right i
mean the greatest nation
here and there but like actually true
happiness came from
laughing with my family and my friends
are there any childhood memories
pleasant or painful ones that stand out
do you know
i mean like you know whenever i think
about my
north korea the interesting is there's
no color
i mean one is because north korean
country has no color right most of
things are unpaved
and trees all cut down we have no fear
so people cut down trees to make food
so but only that like even what we were
wearing was like no color
so it's um interesting like memory to
look back what about fashion i've
noticed from
sort of uh you now you're you're
you have quite an incredible sense of
fashion so
contrast that with your time in north
korea how do you remember
fashion just or ways that people could
express themselves visually
was it all bland there was no word for
fashion in north korea
we didn't even know it was not even our
dictionary so of course i did not know
what victoria secret motors were i
didn't even know what motors were so
when i came out i learned
more there was a job and like what is
that and i'm still confused
so there's so many jobs that we have
here doesn't exist in north korea
what was life like in north korea as
compared to the rest of the world so
maybe you said there's no internet
uh 24-hour electricity
is a luxury you do not have what about
food
what about water what about basic human
rights
i think that's the thing like when
people were asking me can you tell me
about
like life in north korea and in the past
i was like
i cannot describe it to you and
initially i thought oh because of my
english that i cannot find the words
it's not that it's a different planet
the common sense that we have doesn't
exist there
like people literally do not know the
concept of
romantic love or human rights or liberty
so when i'm thinking back to my country
it's uh you know like as you cannot
imagine your life on mars right now
it's like that kind of difference i grew
up never seen the map of the world
i never knew that i was asian like the
regime told
me that i was keemer's son the first
king race
and then our calendar doesn't begin when
jesus christ was born
our candor begins where hymns was born
so
we and history was forgotten to us they
didn't touch
us about of course christianity or like
the
big bang like our history began when kim
was born
so everything was forgotten to us and
it was like different meaning i mean
feeling of existence
you know it's not even like the same
life i literally think
that was almost like my past life and
this is like a new life that i began
you're you're almost like a different
human being now absolutely
yeah so you've uh i have to say
i often say that my favorite book is
animal farm by george orwell
i've read it i don't know how many times
and so i was really happy to
hear that that was uh of the many books
excellent books they
will hopefully talk about you've
mentioned that an animal farm had a big
impact on you
it was the book that kind of
uh led to uh a kind of awakening for you
maybe
can you describe what impact it had so
after going to what i went through right
and i arrived in south korea after many
years of journey
they were saying so kim's were dictators
and south korea is not colonized by
american investors
and americans first of all not bastards
they're good people
and then they say everything that you
believed in north korea was a lie
it was a propaganda then at 15 i was
thinking
so if everything that i believe was a
lie how do i know what you're telling me
it's not like
that was so hard how do i trust ever
again
and i just it was chaos and belief right
i did not know what was true anymore
and that's the moment few years later i
read this book
like animal farm just by mistake it was
a very short book in the library i was
like okay i can finish that quickly
and when they're ending that like last
chapter right they
could not see between the pigs and
humans anymore like that sentence
i just understood everything what
happened i just it made
every sense to me what happened to me my
people
and to my country yeah that there's uh
there's so many things they could say
about that book yeah there's a haunting
nature
to the young and i guess spoiler alert
but you should have read this
already if you're listening to this um
at the end the animals were looking to
the humans
and to the pigs and they couldn't see
the difference and then there's this
kind of
gradual transition
from the initial revolutionary steps
of animals fighting for their freedom to
slowly
uh the pigs gaining control went from
four legs good two legs bad two uh
four legs good two legs better
even better i think yeah like that they
were so like
gradually transitioning the ideology
under which the farm operates
and i think the gradual nature of that
where basically you have generations
born not
knowing how things were in the past
and that's that's what makes the most
kind of for me
haunting transition from freedom
to slavery to suffering to injustice
all those things and the animals don't
know they're part of that
and also for me personally
i've always kind of found a kinship with
boxer the
the horse because i just i'm kind of an
idiot i just work really hard
to work hard and i just love the idea of
working hard for an ideal
mm-hmm and the tragic nature of
to the end that horse boxer working his
ass off
for for the pride uh
for others uh but yeah for the pride of
the farm you know
uh and then the the the pigs
giving him sort of using that but then
just sending him to the slaughterhouse
anyway
when he was no longer useful i mean
there's so many tragic elements that
echo everything i've seen in the soviet
union
and many of the elements that you see in
even
harsher more drastic way in north korea
if there's something hopeful you pull
from that book
like within the suffering within the
gradual decline
the taking away the freedom there were
still moments of beauty it seemed like
it can be but i think for me was
when i was ending the last page of the
book
until that point i was angry towards a
dictator
why do you do this as a human being i
was so angry
dreaming of killing him revenging my
father the people that he cared but when
i was ending the last chapter
actually everybody was responsible to
create this dystopia in my country
that animals initial animals that when
they're scared
when they receive the first execution
and then they were not doing their job
speaking out and keep questioning
like they had a question and then they
as soon as they feel fear
they silence yeah because of that like
that's when i was like
my grandma knew life could be different
i think the one thing about north
koreans are unique is that
they don't know they're oppressed they
don't know that they are slaves to the
dictator
and the fact that other people know
they're oppressed like in america a lot
of people think they are oppressed
like you are not oppressed you don't
even know the definition of oppression
and like that's like when the new
animals came
the new animals didn't even know what
the life could be like
there's no alternative for them to
compare even
and i was like my grandmother knew why
didn't they not do anything about it and
they were just scared they kept
silent and everybody was responsible
so the people who knew were too afraid
to say
and then there's people that just didn't
even know
and i don't know what's more terrifying
about
human nature looking at this group of
people who are
afraid to say that things could be
otherwise and then the group of people
that
don't even know it could be better no
it's uh i don't know that this is that's
the reason i've returned to that book
often because it's such maybe because
it's interesting using animals to
represent ideas that were very human
it almost allows you to explore the
darkness of human nature
without sort of being uh broken by it so
you mentioned anger when i watch your
interviews
you're really calm and collected not
just your interviews
you know instagram the way you present
yourself you um
i don't know it seems like you're almost
at peace with the world
um is there in private times when you're
just angry
do you feel fear do you go to dark
places depression
all those kinds of things are are you
able to put that world that you were in
behind you
it's a joke because i talk about north
korea every single day
and i still rescue people like from
china and russia and other countries
right and sometimes
our rescue mission fails and they get
capture and send back
i still have uh people in north korea
report to me
so like when i talk to my sister who
chose to not
be in this life activist life she forgot
most of things
and like for the other hand i like
remember everything
so sometimes it's uh it's it's a
blessing to
keep reminded of how because it's you
know they say
happiness relative thing it is sometimes
i mean a good thing is also people say
because nobody was fooling
when you're growing up everybody was
suffering you should have been okay
right but know like if you are suffering
that degree
no matter even if there's no comparison
like if you're in nazi german
in a holocaust right in the in the
concentration camp
i'm sure nobody was better than them i'm
sure they were
suffering is the same thing i suffered
but now because i'm
in this place i can compare easily right
getting that perspective
but it is true like i still have days
that i cannot get out of bed
and i'm really hoping like that where it
was elam was talking about downloading
your brain blah blah
yeah like if maybe technology develops
that i can download some part of my
memory
and then i can erase it like when was i
deleted
and that would be so much better what i
this is uh
sorry for the tough question but if i
came to you if elon
came to you and said we can erase that
part of your memory
would you do it some days i would do it
for sure
and my mom would do a hundred percent my
sister would do it
all other defectors know they do a
hundred percent
for me i hesitated because i'm a witness
so if i delete that part i don't know
how real that can be
but it is painful like after i talk
give a speech right i mean i'm fine but
somehow i'm depressed
sometimes if the talk was very intense
i'm like depressed for three weeks
it takes a while for me to be recharged
but i don't know why it is you know
yeah i i just don't know yeah
well there's also the and uh there's a
guy named victor franco who wrote the
book
masters for meaning and there's some
aspect um
where so he talks about the holocaust
and you can in the in those moments of
suffering still discover meaning
still discover happiness in the simplest
of joys
like while starving you know a little
piece of bread could be a source of
incredible joy yeah and there's some
aspect
in which that experience gives you a
clarity about the world
like somehow experiencing suffering
allows you to deep
deeply experience joy yeah and love
and also empathize with the suffering of
others and like it's almost like
brings you closer to other humans so
it's
this double-edged sword that um
that the highest of joys sometimes
are catalyzed by suffering and it's hard
to know what to do with that you see
that with
world war ii the stories of soldiers
that have suffered but
some of the closest bonds
of brotherhood of just pure love was
experienced by them
and it's it sucks that our brains are
like this
you know the love requires hardship i
don't know why that is
yeah that's like that's thing of course
in my journey i learned
how to survive right when to not trust
and when to run but i think
most of i was keep learning what it
means to be a human being
i think that was like ultimate thing i
was keep learning and
i still don't know fully what it means
but i do think it seems
like suffering is necessary for
people to be grateful and even be joyful
to sometimes
yeah so i talk about love quite a bit
and you mentioned that romantic love uh
i'm fascinated about
love in many aspects but
you mentioned romantic love was
forbidden in north korea yeah
what do you think about love now that
you've
kind of discovered it what's the role of
love in life
why was it so why do you think it was
forbidden in north korea
so the tragic thing about north korea is
not only just banning shakespeare
like we don't even know what romeo and
juliet is right our movies is never
about love stories
but then also they ban the love between
mother and daughter
wife and husband and you know
and you between your friends they deny
you being a human
so only love that i knew was when i
described my feeling towards the leader
and in the written form that was the
only love that people know in north
korea
and now i'm like there are many loves
you can experience
i mean i think you definitely love
science right
but imagine that if you're being denied
that yeah
so there are so many loves in life but
in north korea
all of those things are denied and i
think
for me is love what makes you tick
like you know love for your child love
for your parents
love your friends love for even yourself
that is denied so i mean many people say
like love is an option but like then why
do you live
i think we live to love and it doesn't
have to be romantic love it can be
anything
but finding love any in any person or
you know any subject i think that's a
goal i think that's when people find the
meaning in something
yeah i think a lot of romantic love is
just one sort of part of it
yeah one echo of the some core thing
yeah science i love science i love
robots all of those things and
it sounds like deliberately or not
the north korean regime wants to channel
that very
deep aspect of the human spirit all
towards the leader
yeah that's it that's the only thing
they allow us to fear
and know about so i remember i mean you
read 1984 by georgia where
it talks about double think and double
speak
who controls the language who controls
thoughts
and why he does talk about as they go
they like eliminate a lot of words
right now like later one word can
represent 10 different things
and like what fascinates me is like how
many
vocabulary meaning people can have and
like when i literally came out i
remember i went even to san francisco
and someone came to me and hugged me and
then he was a guy who's like
oh baby don't worry i'm gay i was like
what the heck is gay i don't know
right and then they try to go to hotel
room and google the gay
and i think oh that's what you meant and
like that like
they deny what that is i'm sure there
are gays in north korea i'm sure there
is
but you don't know what it is and
like that they eliminate words so the
fact that you know the concept
that is a state is much better than and
that's the thing a lot of people like
when you're born you somehow know what
justice is
what liberty is and it's all somebody
taught you that
and like that's the thing why people is
like oh humans are
inherently know what is right what is
wrong what is oppression and like
no that's like bs you gotta learn that's
fascinating that words
give rise to ideas so like
as a child one of the ways to learn
about justice and freedom
is to first learn the word and then to
ask well what is it
yeah the concept yeah and if you don't
have the word for it
then you never have the kind of first
spark
that leads to you trying to be curious
about it that's interesting and
controlling the words
and then yeah i mean your thoughts you
control the thoughts
there's so many echoes i mean i have uh
it's it's a very different but perhaps a
very similar experience which is the
journey of my family
through the soviet union
because there is a love of country there
is a pride of the people
yeah like you are proud of your family
in general yeah
but um i wonder how much of that is
polluted
by the the propaganda i think a lot too
for sure yeah it is to this day i'm like
my father who died in china and
he was tortured and then he died
he wanted to go back before his bath
right
and then it's like that if you go about
you're gonna be executed
and like i wanna be executed he wanted
to go back to north korea
to be executed so he can be buried in
his own land
and then his last wish was if i die
criminate me and then bring my ashes
back to my country
when i'm dead i still want to be my
country
and this is nationalism this is a
propaganda right
and but now like it's the same thing
like
it's the same thing if i die i somehow
buried in my land
and i still feel like i'm the outsider
i'm always longing for my home it's a
horrible home
yeah like let people say what's your
dream like do you want to be a president
do you need to run for office like
i just want to go home that's my dream
right
and people here don't get it ever yeah i
um
i don't know what to do with that i love
my country and i think for me my country
is
um the united states and perhaps it will
be for you too one day
it is i think it's becoming new years
has been a very special place in my
heart
i think this is the first place i felt
like i i feel like home
and i mean i was in south korea longer
and i didn't feel that way
so so i think there were very different
life stories but i think
it's almost two different people the for
me it's the person that was in the
soviet union and the person that's
here those are two different people for
that previous person's home
in the soviet union and he's part of me
yeah
and i suppose in that same way you're
you know your first maybe two decades of
life
are somehow longing for the home that is
north korea
yeah and your next two decades of life
might be finding a home in the united
states
yeah your your dad uh can you tell the
story
of um of his struggle
um uh of his death
i mean first do you miss him do you
think about it
all the time like i had a son when i was
22.
and i had ivf three times and
i know as you see i'm like 80 pounds but
back now like 75 pounds
because of my master of your
malnutrition somehow my body is very
different
and so after three times of av
ivf after 23 i was still wanting family
and the reason i wanted him is
because i felt so guilty for my father
that he never seen this world
i somehow like when you're so desperate
you become illogical
like i want to believe in the recon like
buddhist idea right you come back to
life
and i prayed please come to me like as
my son so i will take care of you like
come back
and when i was pregnant with my son even
though i planted pregnant with a girl
doctor made a mistake he became a boy
so i made his middle name like my
father's name since i think he's the
only
american got north korean name
[Laughter]
it is so he's so part of your father
isn't your son
yeah that's how i that's
how i make the sense of it and that's
how i move forward
like if i like as a logical human being
you you know when you're dead you're
done maybe that's that's what i at least
used to think
but then life just become too unbearable
and somehow that's the thing like
we tell ourselves stories in order to
live and that's how i came within my
title of the book in order to live
i had to tell myself a lot of stories to
overcome a lot of things
i think i was part of it
can you tell the story of um you
escaping north korea
to china yeah i think
it's it's a thing it's amazing
even though i was like 13 my like
life outside north korea is almost like
it went by like one second
and my life till that point was like
eternity
i remember being in china i arrived
there at the end of march
at 13 and by october it was six months
passed
and i literally felt like i lived
eternity
and one day living in china
felt like living one year one day was a
war like
surviving through one day was so hard
every night i was like i cannot believe
i got done one day today
that was the thing i was grateful for
before i went to bed
okay i survived i didn't get captured
and i made you another day on earth so
the experience
of the minutes is is what fear
fear of being captured fear
loss everything so
because i mean i sold my own mom in
china
to survive too
so it was more than that and
it's not feeling i think that's the
thing in china
i learned not to fear and
after my escape was challenging i didn't
feel anything
and it was hard not feeling anything is
a torture it's a bigger torture you can
never feel like
even you fear sadness that's better than
not feeling anything
and i fear something when i had my son
that's when i started healing so he was
a miracle
to save me but yeah in china it wasn't
even
fear like it was numb you were numb yeah
it was like paralysis
yeah just overwhelming
on the uncertainty of your future did
you have a sense what your future
held at the time like what do you even
even feature i don't even know that word
right
like a lot of times i was looking at
myself like i left my body and like just
looking at me
and just not feeling it it's not like
i'm scared for her
i'm like sad for her just looking at me
like
oh that's interesting wow not feeling
anything
and me like being raped going through
every emotion of life to survive right
like
but like like somehow i don't know
you say so or something like looking at
it just like
you feel nothing you don't feel anything
for that person
so even with your mom like what was
was there some
i don't know some warmth that you were
able to extract
from the connection with your mom yeah
of course i think that
made me survive i had a very strong
connection
with my family and i think that's what
kept me going
to do all of that i think as you said i
escaped at 13.
my sister at the age of 16 escaped with
her friend
first and i was going to escape with her
but
one day i got like really bad
stomachache and my parents took me to
hospital
and north korean hospital they don't
have like x-ray machines like they don't
even have electricity
they like literally using one needle to
inject everybody
yeah and people don't die from cancer
and north korea you die from infection
and fever and
hunger right it's most likely you're
gonna die more by being treated by
doctors and
not being treated i think i was lucky
even though they thought i had appendix
they they operate on me without any
painkiller
and i didn't get infection i survived
so that's how i got delayed to escape to
my sister
and she left me a note in my bedside
saying like follow this lady
and this is like another trick about
human trafficking right
she sold me to china as a sexual slave
and she executed fully later and she had
she was executed for that later she had
five daughters
and she sold all her children to china
and we can now sitting here judging on
like how heartless you are
selling your own children to china and
as a sexual slave they were like her
children were
7 10 years old but that was the only way
for her to save her children
and if she didn't start me that day i
would be dead right
now so i'm grateful that she sold me
and i think that's the thing is life is
so crazy
you cannot judge it's just so complex
and yeah that's how she changed my life
by selling me
she sold my mom and myself in 2007 to
china
so you're grateful for that you're
grateful for that suffering
of course i am grateful because the
alternative is worse
i would not be here with you you never
knew i existed
what do you make of the others suffering
in the world today
the people there in north korea
so that is part of the your
of your life's work is helping those
people mm-hmm
what do you think about them what should
people know about them
i think that's when i get angry whenever
i think about them
like your anger directed at
at
the heartlessness of people the
ignorance of people
like so when i got on north korea
going through all of them and i went to
south korea one day
i was watching television and just like
famous korean k-pop stars and crying and
doing some fundraising concerts and i
literally thought i was like oh my god
something is a horrible going wrong in
this country why are these people crying
it was cheery like campaign and then
later was
showing that it was the animal rights
campaign
to helping out cats and puppies in the
shelters
yeah do you know anybody she has their
tears like that
to another human being right now like no
right people rather give a million
dollars to save some dolphins
than saving these children right now
being raped in china
and i think i love elon musk i read this
right i love these people want to like
go the moon
mars and like people told them like yeah
you went we went to the moon like i did
not know in north korea
i think that's what upsets me okay why
there is not even one single human
with that kind of brilliance in their
brain
they they can't save so much suffering
that nobody does anything
i think that's when i i feel like hard
to find help in humanity
and that's when i get so upset because
think about like even biden or trump or
obama
they know what's happening in north
korea exactly right i mean if we see
satellite photos
there's public executions i mean the u.n
says this is the holocaust happening
again
and is it happening if the holocaust
happening again how
why how are you okay doing nothing about
it
but somehow humans are able to okay not
doing anything
and this is like this is
hard like when people say i'm gonna
change the world i want to make a
difference like
it's hard to believe it you know
yeah that we can turn our back to human
suffering at scale when it's right in
front of us i mean that makes you think
about the holocaust
this is just everybody was looking the
other way
yeah because it was almost too hard to
look at it
no it's not it's the easier thing like
it does the thing
i was like here to speak at the south by
southwest few years ago
and like they're everywhere talking
about like elon musk project going to
the moon right
we're gonna be multi spell like species
i was like
back then i did not even know who he was
so if you're guys
trying to go after this earth you
haven't even explored our earth yet
you cannot go to north korea right now
you haven't explored that part of our
our like planet can we do that first and
then move on
explore the landscape of human suffering
like alleviate suffering in the world
there's
um there's a lot of suffering happening
in africa
that has to do with disease and for some
reason
it's even though we turn our back to
that kind of suffering too
we still can try to do something about
it
and there's still efforts uh in terms of
uh health care in terms of medicine in
terms of bioengineering in terms of like
all these efforts to help people from
disease but like
that's almost like converting into an
engineering problem and trying to solve
it
that somehow is easier for us humans but
when there's obvious sort of
non-disease-related
torture of humans we look the other way
yeah whether it's china or it's north
korea
yeah i mean that has to be changed
somehow
we'll have to change that somehow this
is the thing right now like
the china like they bring the xinjiang
vigors right dave
they say oh this vitamin take it and
then it kills their sperm
and make them not reproduce their birth
rate gone down something 47 to something
50
in the one year time it's a genocide in
21st century
and they get those people and get their
like organs out
imagine if there's some people who do
that with cutie puppies and cats
there's gonna be insane amount of
product they're gonna destroy everything
and this is like a human nature that i
don't get
why there's so much anti-human sentiment
in this modern world like we don't have
to like
the the fact that i was saying like the
fact that you care about animals rights
it's beautiful because you care about
something who cannot speak for
themselves
the fact that we care about animals is
because they cannot speak for themselves
right they don't have that
ability and there are many people who
cannot speak for themselves right now
and why do you refuse to be the voice
for them
because they're simply being a human and
maybe it connects to us
not being proud of who we are like maybe
i don't know what it is why do they deny
humans
this way maybe they don't like
themselves
yeah it's almost um we would have to
acknowledge some dark things about
ourselves in order to start helping
what's the solution so you know i see
two solutions
one is in the military side
yeah it's uh assassination
or the full-on invasion
and then on the activism side
which is figuring out ways to um
like like you said sort of let people in
north korea
understand their situation sort of from
within try to reform
or maybe there's others obviously there
could be activism
from the outside to build up momentum
for the entirety of the world
especially the world that it's not just
the united states or europe but also as
russia and china and so on
what what are your ideas here how we can
what we can do as individuals and as
countries
i think the first thing that we can do
is speak about
chinese role in this sponsoring
dictatorship in north korea
like i haven't had so much struggle
talking about north korea right they say
how north korea is possible why is it
like the way like this is
99 accountability going to
ccp kim jong-un cannot last
without chinese have even one week this
is
completely funded this holocaust is
funded by ccp
but if you talk about in the mainstream
of course they don't buy it
and i think it's in a way north korea is
a lot easier to
serve than even in the middle east
there's nothing conflict like
between people there's no ideology no
religion nothing
people are peaceful right there's not
even one civil
any discontent among the people or
problem is there's a dictator funded by
the second economic power in the world
and
even any military they know if they kill
kim jong-un they're gonna get killed by
chinese
nobody can dare to stand up against kim
jong because of china is backing it
so somehow here in the west we
collectively
acknowledging that china is the
responsible person
for these crimes against humanity in
north korea then we can somehow
i don't know china exactly we're
we're failing to do that in a way
in all kinds of avenues of life of
public life
because uh for many reasons they're
probably primarily financial
but it also i'm against
i don't know maybe you can correct me
i'm against sort of
making china this evil enemy
because i've seen this with russia as
well and i don't think that leads to
progress
i think you want to highlight like you
basically want to
help china the chinese people
become the best versions of themselves
so speak to the chinese people
and not fear not uh making the leaders
of china
the like into these caricatures of
devils
i i feel like the cold war the way it
was done in russia i just for
both sides they were caricaturing each
other through propaganda and the result
was not productive at all
it did not help russia become the best
country it could be did not help america
become the best country it could be
and the same thing with china i feel
like making them into this enemy
like being afraid of china being
making them into the thing that's going
to spy on us that's going to destroy the
rest of the world
that's not going to help china like
reform themselves they're going to plant
their feet
the dictators the evil people will
become more evil
the power hungry will become more like
they will centralize the power more it
feels like
um maybe naive but it feels like
it should be like again
love not violence that solves this thing
now of course in north korea it's like
long gone 80 years
almost 80 years old you can't love is
not going to solve that problem or
i mean i don't it's very difficult they
have tried that
because of the sunshine policy which is
there's a two people walking down the
street and the sun and the wind made a
battle
so who can take off that man take off
jacket so wind
tried to blow as much air he could and
then that man was
like putting more like his jacket on
right not taking off but sunshine came
like okay i'm gonna give him a lot of
worms
and then he took his jacket out and came
out so that was the theory let's give
north korea as much love they want
let's give them a lot of money whatever
they want let's give to them
do they know that we are not here to
attack them yeah and north korea what
they did with the guy who did the
sunshine policy in south korea named kim
daesung
won the nobel peace prize for that and
kim
kim jong-il used the money to build
nuclear weapons
so that's how they came with the nukes
so i think
that's the thing i hope your love serves
problems
but there's got to be a way and that's
the the hope is with the 21st century
you can directly speak to the people
somehow when there's no internet when
there's
nothing like that it's hopeless i think
china there's a hope
that yeah the china is still connected
to the internet i love your optimism
i have seen the actual dark side of
china
on the underground i hope
i think that's the thing people here in
the west right they say oh how can it be
that bad
they ask me like i walking passing this
young teenager man in near the world
with my sister
he's like intestine coming out through
his bad way
and even in that moment what he wanted
was
please give me food he was hungry his
intestine is hanging out of his body
yeah and he's
asking for food do you know what humans
demand when they die in north korea all
they want is eating
right yeah and people say oh nothing can
be that bad
but people just here haven't seen an
actual true evil would you say that the
evil comes from a tiny minority of
people
or does it permeate much larger parts of
the population
like if we look at sex trafficking
how many people
like is it 99.9 of the people are s
are um
longing to do good in the world
or is there is it uh
or do we all have the capacity for evil
in certain kind of environment certain
kind of
uh governmental structures inspire a
large
percent of the population to do bad
things
i think humans are capable of anything
there is no exception
i don't think there's any saying to born
with a morality
i think in north korea you can say
initially that there's few guys in the
top
wanting the power and then doing this
but
eventually made a society where people
don't even know what
compassion is we don't know the concept
of we don't know that you need to feel
bad for another human being when they're
suffering
the fact that you know compassion is in
your knowledge that's why you do that
humans need to learn it's not anything
bad about human nature it's just saying
humans are capable of everything we are
the most adaptable species on the planet
that's why we
created the internet like talking this
way right
now other animals have done it because
we are so adaptable
that is a good thing and that's a bad
thing so in the adaptive situation
they all can be i mean during the
holocaust right those people
they could have been capable of good too
if they were exposed to different system
yeah and that's why when people
underestimate evil
that's what scares me evil is evil
it's a different thing it's a completely
different thing
and of course i could really get your
idea we don't want to isolate 1.3
billion human beings in on earth by
chinese but the thing is we are talking
about this
regime not the people i love chinese
people i speak chinese
i love like all about the country but
this system
does promote evil well that's an
optimistic view actually because
we can fix systems yeah it's harder to
fix people
so if we fix systems then the people are
adaptable absolutely as you said
i mean that and then the question is uh
first of all you have to
talk about it just as you're doing
you're right now like this little flame
that burns bright and it's really
important for north korea but just keep
talking about it
until there's until hopefully
leads to at the highest levels of power
revolutionizing the systems in the world
and then
uh in china and in north korea do you
see
north korea being a potential instigator
of a nuclear war
they will not start any korean war as
long as they can do whatever they want
right now
right north korea's army not designed to
fight the enemy
they designed to prevent their own
people the quteta and the revolution
with their own citizens
that is 1.6 million north korea
with a tiny country the fourth largest
armies in the world
so this this country designed to fight
with their own citizens
and the army the fourth largest in the
world
is designed to basically fight its own
people oppress their own people that's
what north korean military is about
okay let me uh ask you some
aspects about north korean life can you
describe the seongbon
system of uh ascribed status used in
north korea
yeah so that's a very interesting thing
right right now there are a lot of
people playing with this ideology of
like
democratic socialism socialism communism
whatever you call marxism leninism right
they have all like these similar
features where
we give collective power to a certain
entity
and they will make the decision for the
bigger good
right and north korea came up with the
idea
the kimir song he was the leninist he
was marxist
saying i'm gonna create the most equal
society on human face
so it was a communist north korea and
then
they came up with this tumbling system
it's a family caste system
three b categories warrior wavering and
hostile
and then in between three classes they
divide into 50 different
classes so a lot of people don't even
know which exact class you belong to
that's a sacred golem document and
that's how they decide your future so in
no way north korea
before you're born your life is
determined for you
and this is normal joke right they
dreamed of creating the most equal
society
they ended up with became most inequal
society in the
face of humanity so there are 50
different classes
and where the one guy on the top became
a god
so when this animal farm as we keep
saying like there's so many
all the animals are equal and someone
and more equal than others
exactly but but it's not only it's just
more equal
one guy in our school became a god
because north korea was born
out of uh marxist ideals yeah
from stalin can you comment on
uh juche ideology which seems to
be its own kind of socialism
but uh with unique aspects here
it really does ideologically says the
importance of having a great leader
yeah is there some interesting
similarities or differences that you can
comment on
between other implementations of
communism throughout history
the soviet union china elsewhere
so tutor is very unique it came around
the 90s after soviet union collapsed
so before that north korea was very
still loyal to the marxist and
melanianism
which is state takes care of you we are
going to give you the right education
health care your livelihood you
everybody's going to be equal
you're going to have in the working
collective form collective workplace
everybody collectively do things
together and let's work for the paradise
but 1991 the soviet union collapsed
and until then north korea was heavily
subsidized by soviet union's aid
and then soviet didn't give them
anything so now three million people die
on the streets
the regime then came up with the idea
okay our goal
is what is successful ruling for us is
keeping the 10 percent
of population alive which is in the
capital pyongyang
so they design the hunger games there is
a capital
13 other districts everybody on the
countryside on purpose being starved
so those people who are starving cannot
thinking about meaning of
life cannot thinking about shooting to
the moon right they're not gonna think
about anything or they're gonna think
it's like finding next meal
all on purpose is man-made famine
international community was begging to
give north korea food
why not stood at the u.n they begged to
give north korea formula
medicine and food they are begging can
you please feed your people and kimchon
said no thank you
last year like we knows had a horrible
horror flooding south korean prisons are
begging
can you get can i give you please some
medicines like no
because he wants to be the one provider
he doesn't want people to think other
people giving him the thing
so on purpose other people are starving
and the truth
idea is that's when you're coming from
so until that communism was about like
steady speaking being a
father figure takes care of all your
needs right give the power to us
and you are all good but north korea
regime says okay
now we cannot give people's rations so
which means
means self-reliance you need to take
care of yourself
while you're giving every right to us so
now
in 1990s the regime told us okay
we are not going to give you russian you
cannot trade
that's illegal but you find your own way
to survive
so be self-reliant that's what to say
and you know but when you're a god you
can do whatever you want you don't need
to make a sense
that's the difference being a god and
being a leader
even it is religion it's not falsifiable
you cannot challenge it
god's way is suspicious god works in the
mysterious way
so when you're god people are not gonna
say oh this doesn't make sense right
you're gonna okay whatever god says
we as a human being we can never change
these thoughts
it is unbelievable what regimes can do
the there's something about
famine you know
that um is another
is another level of evil to me
you know what stalin did in ukraine in
the 30s
yeah [ __ ] him
yeah this is what torture is
cannibalism yeah and um
north korea too they humans right now
in 21st century seven billion people on
this earth right now
you make the enough food for 10 billion
people
nobody should be starving right now it's
worrisome to me the humanity is moving
forward with the technological advances
blah blah we are going so
fast in in advancement and we are living
this like 25
million human beings in the cage
completely leaving them behind
and north korea is living like 16
centuries i never
like this morning i was taking a shower
beautiful shower
like one never knew what shower was i
was bathing few few times a year going
to the like
river how do i even know what shampoo is
and this is
how human beings in 20 persons living
and it doesn't bother us and rather
most people obsess being a vegan and
like
how how do you reconcile this
i think we get used to stuff very
quickly we get used to comforts that's
just the way of human life you
you take the beautiful things for
granted
so i try to appreciate everything i have
so whether it's
uh like the food i have now or like the
luxury to have a diet and
to be struggling with that yeah or just
the basic simple moments of being alive
with the people i love
or actually i get like i think i'm on
drugs all the time because
i feel like just even like uh this mug
everything on this table
just brings me joy but it's
like filling your life with joy in the
full
capitalistic american way you can still
at the same time
uh not feel too bad about yourself no
and still
focus on the the suffering in the world
and i think
there's some way
that in trying to build a better world
in america it has ripple effects
elsewhere sort of like so i'm a fan of
rockets in space it sounds perhaps
counter-intuitive but sending raucous to
space
will help solve the north korea
a problem because it lets
people dream yeah and build
cool stuff so it's not the rocket it's
the other people
that like are inspired by the rocket and
then look to
other problems in the world i mean
that's what elon did is like he saw
problems in the world and saw like what
can i do to help it
and i think the north korea one is a
tough one though
because that's ultimately has to do
with revolutionizing government
china china that's what it takes
changing chinese communist party is
impossible
that's why we couldn't solve north korea
for that many decades but
it's china well for now it's china but
it's china
it's um so it's uh
russia it's certain aspects of the
united states and struggling with that
uh one of the you know there's a bunch
of technologies that are striving at
this
um for example uh i don't know what your
thoughts about cryptocurrencies
i love it so like there's a idea that
money could be a way to destroy or to
challenge the power centers of the world
yeah
so if you give if you take away the
power from fiat currency and give it to
this thing that can't be controlled by
government that's cryptocurrency whether
it's bitcoin ethereum all those kinds of
things
that's a way to get money into the hands
of people
to where the government can't take that
money away
but north koreans don't have electricity
no internet
so yeah we can do that with china we can
do it a lot of african dictatorship
countries
right i do think big cryptocurrency is
such a fascinating technology
right i think this is an amazing
experiment i mean
that power is in our hands i'm the huge
advocate believer
but i think nurses too behind yeah you
know i think that's what is unique about
north korea is that
most of things that we talk about is now
it's different planet literally
the common law that we have is now
applicable
what about kim jong-un kim jong-un yeah
is he intentionally evil or is he
mindless mindlessly propagating an evil
system created by his
ancestors what's your sense of the man
so with the keemer's song i can give him
more than i feel that
he was a initial true believer of
communism
but then as later he gained the power he
realizing
i think i guess back then he thought
most of people are dumb my individuals
don't
so therefore i need to make a decision
for all of you
that pure arrogance came from out of him
even that i can tolerate okay
fine and kim jong-il who never like yeah
fine he grew up in that system too but
kim jong-un is very unique
this guy was educated in switzerland
in the heart of democracy he knew how
human beings
should be treated as a child event
when you're a child your brain is very
susceptible
right you change anybody like why the
mall was so pleasant
changing young people's minds like
that's every revolutionary they do right
they go
change young people's minds first this
guy was so obsessed with the power
him being a god even starting in
switzerland
didn't change him and that's why i think
that's a pure evil
you know i can't give him more benefit
or thought to his grandfather and father
but when it comes to kim jong-un this is
like what pure evil looks like
pure selfish being yeah that's what it
looks like
is there is there some sense where he's
justifying
everything he's doing to himself or do
you think there's a psychopathic
aspect to where he enjoys the suffering
i think in his life right i read a lot
about like north korea a lot of cia
documents a lot of intelligence people
work there
and even like worked in north korean
type elites and escaped i
could hear about them so kim jong-un
when they're born they treat like gods
so they never have a sense of them being
a human
they're like equal with others for them
like if you're just any kind of
tool like that what napoleon like thing
does right
anybody's a tool like once boxer dies
you get him slaughtered for my cause
and they do not even feel guilty about
it because they don't view us that you
deserve you are worthy of it
yeah that's right so it's not like he
even fears he doesn't even recognize the
suffering
like of course you you this this is what
you do serving me
because i am i am this so i think that's
like
beyond that like he's not like suffering
his enters his minds
he doesn't even think what we go through
you see he thinks is himself
as a as a god yeah and then everybody
else is just uh
tools that are disposable right there
was rumors
several times of him dying yeah do you
think he is
um obviously his health
is not good do you think he will die
soon what happens if
kim jong-un dies
well when it comes to north korea
anybody knows what they're going
what kim jong-un does it's lie right
nobody knows i'm sure cia knows but they
may never reveal that
cia has enough intelligence to can tell
where kim jong-un is what he's doing
they just don't assassinate him because
they don't see the
needs of it right now because do you
think they can assassinate him they
can't they do have ability abilities
why the hell do they not assassinate
them because they don't care they don't
care about the suffering of 25 million
people
they gotta pay the price if they sell
assassin kim jong-un
they gotta pay the price there will be
financial there'll be political price to
pay
it will anger china absolutely that is a
huge piece for them and then they'll
have to deal
obviously there'll be financial military
consequences of having to deal with
the turmoil the uncertainty yeah the
revolutions that will spring up
yeah that's the thing like that's why
they don't want to take that risk they
don't want to do anything
the u.s now became very passive when
they pursue these mortal values to the
rest of the world
they did the same thing with the
holocaust in the early days actually
yeah they were like just they didn't
care
and that's what they're always policy
has been they don't care i mean
so if kim jong-un dies it's gonna be
very hard for north korea to replace
anybody in his position because kim's is
a brand
it's not just like a leader for us right
whenever we think of kim
who came with my mind like who's like
almost god figure
like north korea is the number 10
religions in the world
they copy the bible so if you believe
that
if there are people believing that god
and jesus christ
how do you not believe that north korea
believes in the same thing so kim
il-sung's grandfather and his parents
were
devout christians so kim your son was
grew up just like christian like word
verses
so when he finding his country he said
i love my people so much that i'm giving
you my son kim jong-il
his body dies but he spirits with us
forever
who can know how many hair i have what i
think and when we suffer
we go to paradise with him and when you
block every single information going
into country of course people are gonna
believe it
so who would be the successor if he dies
he has a son
a first son born 2009 and not
not old enough if he dies now so
either his sister might rule for of
short amount time as not like a leader
but like replay like
temporary placement and then when the
sun
is old enough he might take it off
because it's a kingdom
that's most likely and china will do
everything they can
to maintain that status call for the
north korean regime
so north korean people have no option
here
we just need some leader to courageously
come up and do the right thing
so we can't just wait this out no we
can't it's not something that takes
its course and not gonna change like we
not even know that
economic freedom does not bring
political freedom we know in china
it doesn't that's that's unique thing
about freedom
you gotta fight for it otherwise you
don't never get it
freedom is something has to be fought
and if nobody fighting for freedom it's
not gonna be there
can we talk a little bit about freedom
what what does it mean to you
having had we talked about love in
that same way about freedom having sort
of
discovered it later in life what does it
mean to you
i think every day i i get a new
definition of freedom
it is it's a never-ending journey
having this relationship with being free
and what it means to be
free right i think
i think uh you definitely can live life
without being free
and also happy life too i saw a lot of
nursing
elites who were were fed and have power
but didn't have freedom were
very happy in a way happier than the
people that i found in yeo were like
investment bankers and consultants in
manhattan
and seventy percent of them called like
talk therapists
i was very confused i remember writing
my book in new york
like my editor was saying yeah me you
know like you're traumatized
you need to go talk to therapists and
it's like what is therapy right
what is trauma because in north korea
they don't have word for stress or
trauma because
how can you be stressed in the surgery
is paradise so they don't let you be
knowing what that is yes so and then
they were like
yeah hearing people having problems go
talk to therapists
and i was like like how much is it
actually like 200
per hour and it's discounted rate too
it's like no thank you
[Laughter]
you know i was like you know and we know
that
freedom comes with responsibility
and in a way it's not that easy to be
free
thinking for yourself constantly like
when you
in a way i understand like let's give
government every power we have
let them decide what education that i
get let them decide where i live like
you know
let someone figure that out for me and
that's how north korea began
hoping the government gonna represent my
own interest
believing that they were good and with
that
benefit of thought and good faith you
began the nightmare right
yeah so freedom is not like a gay way to
be happy at all
in a way you can make life a lot more
complex but then it's fun
isn't it you start being for yourself
you start making mistakes
and it's so fun to be free even though
you can be suffering way more
than the people who are not free the
thing about freedom is
when you have freedom you also have the
responsibility for your actions
and that could be a huge burden yeah
because
um if you succeed it's you
but if you fail it's you yeah and
uh if you do horrible things it's you if
you don't do something
for example if you don't help people in
north korea it's you
yeah and that's a huge burden yeah
and living with that burden is a kind of
suffering
i mean there's some aspect in which
freedom is suffering it is suffering
because life is suffering and then
freedom is uh
you as an individual fully living
through that
so you talked you're friends with
michael malus
he believes and so i want to kind of ask
you about government
he believes he's an anarchist and he
believes kind of in
freedom fully implemented in
in human societies meaning that humans
should
all be free to choose how they
um you know transact with each other how
they live together
there shouldn't be a centralized force
that tells you what to do
do you think there's some role for
government
in um in a healthy society yeah so
you if we look at north korea there's
the most horrible implementation
of government but then if we
look at what the united states strives
to be at least
in principle there's uh there's an
ideal of a government that represents
the people and helps the people like is
there is there a place for that kind of
ideal
or is government always going to get us
into trouble i
am not i mean i spoke to michael males i
kept asking
why he's anarchist right and he doesn't
believe in military none of that
and it's i was like i was like i don't
think i want to be in that world
you're describing me that's pretty scary
i want the law enforcement
i want like i don't
in a way that so why equality makes no
sense is that
the fact that when you and i were born
we were born in a very different
capability of thinking
different intelligence different
capability in our physics right
so equality is nonsense you can never
achieve that
right so to me that's when it's very
scary
when the government tries to interforce
equality on everybody that is
impossible that's specifically equality
of outcomes so like
so given that we all started different
places enforce
like measure in some kind of way where
people stand and if they're on equal in
force equality
yeah and that's what leads to the kind
of things that you mentioned with the
class system
right in north korea yeah so i think
that's why
government can be bad they can be very
dumb and
another another thing is that they
cannot know what you want a lot of times
people don't even know what they want
any individual
like how the heck do you assume
government gonna know what is best for
you
nobody knows we just all do our best
i do think that some governments against
switzerland
you know have more give power to the
different state
can be good i think i'm more you know
like giving power to the state
and let individuals decide where they
want to go in within states or
i mean why did you choose taxes right
there's no
income tax right like there's a lot of
things people find texas
like you know charming and they come
here so in a way that
i don't want to be in a one strong
garment it makes
every single thing the same way in a way
i want to kind of experiment
everything you can have anarchy state
there's no police nothing going on you
can be
whatever one you want and you can go on
a stable it's like
abortion is bad blah blah this is bad
all these
conservative values and let the ideas
compete
and let them how they are being tracked
in real real life
but i think it's very scary when the
youth government is getting bigger and
bigger and then they try
to you know make every state under one
big government
and that's like when i get really
alarmed are there things that you see in
the united states
in the current culture that kind of has
echoes of the same things you saw in
north korea
that that worry you that much
absolutely it's it's uh
it's in america now the meritocracy
doesn't matter right it's evil
the white man's idea of like talking
about if you're
competent enough they said oh if you're
coming from which white family
you are going to be competent so other
people don't have a chance but
look at asians who came from nothing is
competent and go to like harvard law
school and medical school
so it doesn't almost it's like there's
no incentive for you to work hard
anymore in the system right now that is
north korea there's no incentive because
you're born
with your class already so no matter
what you do you can never so
the horrible thing about north korean
system is that there is nothing even
holding mary up so if you're coming from
other cultures
that like mega marco join the royal
family and she became a lawyer you go
up by north korea if someone from high
class is going to marry somebody down
you only go down with them that's how
they prevent
classmates right they that kind of
enforces the separation because there's
huge disincentives to go uh to marry to
to
integrate between classes yeah
what do you do about this kind of um you
know
especially in universities but in
companies i'm
thinking about starting a company so i'm
looking at this very carefully
there's these ideas of diversity
and and meritocracy that's a tension so
yeah i think there's
there's a big way in which diversity
broadly defined
is not at all in in tension with
meritocracy so having a variety of
people
backgrounds way of thinking all those
kinds of things is a huge benefit to any
group but the way diversity is often
defined
is by sort of very crude classes
of people whether it's by skin color or
gender
or or or some very kind of large group
way
and that that actually does two things
in my mind one it drowns out real
diversity
or not real but the full spectrum of
diversity
which is like within class diversity of
like
um are you are you somebody
who is um
are you somebody who's exceptionally
good at mathematics are you somebody
who's exceptionally good at psychology
are you good with people
are you good with numbers all that kind
of stuff that i think spans
or intersects in fascinating ways with
these kinds of groups
so that's diversity and then meritocracy
is this
thing that probably the reason i wanted
to move to silicon valley and the reason
i didn't is like
having a fire to change the world within
you like
meritocracy is like i want to be the
best in the world
at this and i will strive and work hard
not stepping on others but like
in purely within yourself be the best
version of yourself
that that idea is
um in some ways being
not celebrated or demonized
is it literally meritocracy is being
demonized right now in america
working hard is a symbol of you
coming from some established family yeah
the fact that you celebrate
accomplishment hard work is a sign of
your
patriarchy whatever thing they call
right and
they want to abolish that they they want
to like stop
giving kids grace that's what they're
already doing right they
want to stop they want like we should
abolish like s 18 in america they take
to go to college right
they won't even abolish this because
yeah some keep kids have no ability to
do math so why do we have to force them
to learn math and that's what comes with
humans overcome challenges yeah that's
what makes us special
but then like because these kids coming
from this family let's find a reason why
they cannot
and then they don't have to do that
thing but they still deserve the same
job they need to be a lawyer
and doctors yeah and that's like what
in north korea was like not there was
not even meritocracy to begin with right
you
these people in the same family the
family the blood right
like if one person does something wrong
it's like collective guilt because i
spoke out
three generations of my family got
punished who are left behind
and then in america i see the same thing
like if you're
somehow great great grandfather on the
slave
now you are privileged and you're guilty
because you are white and geared then
but how do you change your ancestor
how did you have a saying on it and that
is where there's no way out there's no
forgiving there's moving forward
and this current culture in america now
like i remember
at columbia like before class everybody
have to go around of saying
tell us what your pronoun is and
my english might third language i
learned as an adult
even saying he and she i'm confused by
this is a pure mistake
and they say call me day because i'm
gender fluid basically i can be a girl
but next hour you talk to me i'm a boy
right yeah
and if you don't do it right they like
look at you why are you big at
right it makes me so nervous and this is
where i come to
this is a regression of civilization
we are regressing as a humanity here
like the enlightenment all of those
things made us so much
brighter and looking forward and now we
are going backwards
well i think it's there's a pendulum
aspect to it because it's my it's my
hope in terms of backwards so
pendulum goes backwards too but it just
goes back and forth i think
and then uh in the long arc of history
we're making progress
i think all of the discussions of
diversity and
inclusion and all those kinds of things
i always thought that they're healthy
in a in moderation right they should be
a small part of the conversation amongst
other things the the natural asp
like it seems that they kind of have
this way of just consuming all
conversations
it's like the meetings like diversity
and inclusion meetings multiply somehow
where it's like the only thing that
you're talking about it's very kind of
absurd and when i look at uh
even at mit it's it's it's a strangely
disproportionate
amount of discussions about that and
also to me as an engineer those
discussions are very frustrating because
they don't seem to actually
do anything no so like they want
to uh bully people yeah
instead of creating systems that fix
define
like definitive problems and
that in itself that kind of bullying
that's the same kind of
thing you saw in terms of mccarthyism in
america
against the communists you certainly saw
that in soviet union
against everybody who's not communist
it's uh it creates
hate not progress when you talk to
jordan peterson recently and
people should listen to that
conversation it was a fascinating one
i think um he
he almost got emotional on the
discussion about
universities and your experience with
colombia
because he like myself for perhaps
different reasons have a hope
for our academic institutions some of
the most incredible people some of
the most incredible engineering and idea
development innovations happens in
universities and so
we both deeply care about them um
is there something so the reason he got
emotional the reason he was kind of hurt
is
the the the fact that you did not you
were not
deeply inspired by your experience
deeply
it made me dumber it made me scared it
made me terrified
that i had to censor myself in america
like
like are you seriously telling me that
you don't ever censor yourself and when
you talk
do you can you truly say whatever you
want about race
of anything gender we all censor
ourselves let's be honest right we
are all doing that and that's what i
learned like
i thought i was coming to country where
i never needed it like first thing my
mom taught me
growing up in north korea was don't even
whisper
because the birds and mice could hear
you
and i thought okay now america is a
truly the land of the free home of the
brave
you can say anything you want and then
you have
freedom to change your mind and evolve
right
but the people now demand you to be the
perfect version they demand you to be
you cannot change your mind and then
what is the meaning of life you cannot
grow
right you should be feel safe to talk
about anything and then later okay
i was wrong but now if you do that you
gotta like get penalized for it
i mean censorship is a funny thing
because you probably should not say dumb
things
you should try to say things you want to
say in the most eloquent the most
effective way you can so i mean that's
what editing is
right yeah so there's some level of like
being careful with what you say not
because you're afraid
of some overarching kind of group
of bullies but you want to be the best
version of yourself when you express
stuff
but there's some sense where in the
university setting
you can put that self-censorship like
level down more
and say stupid stuff right and explain
and play
because you should be forgiven for that
kind of uh play
especially when you're discussing
difficult aspects of human history
whether
that include racism that that include uh
atrocities
i'm still nevertheless sort of hopeful
but at the same
time i'm i'm surrounded by engineers
yeah so i don't get to interact with
people in humanities much
and it seems like there's a good thing
it's a good thing i i
yeah i don't know um well i do sort of
interact with psychologists but they
haven't touched on those kinds of topics
yet i
i still sort of in defense of psychology
i still i wish he had more numbers yeah
uh but i still feel like most psychology
people
don't partake in this kind of stuff
either they're just doing excellent
research
we're just highlighting this what
america does well
you're kind of highlighting anecdotal
experiences
and uh making a big deal out of them
but that's good because like it's a
slippery slope if those
if those things start to overtake all of
academia it starts becoming a big
problem even in the engineering field so
we should be concerned but it is truly
tragic that somebody who's
exceptionally well read like you whose
fire was stoked first with orwell
that fire should burn bright like this
should not be
you should be writing many books you
know what i mean like and
you'll be you talk to jordan you know
it's very possible
depending what you want to do with your
life that you'll be a future jordan
peterson
right so like that and colombia
should be a place that enriches
that your mind and the fact that it
didn't is
is tragic it's like i was there four
years
it wasn't like i had one class that was
bad in a one semester
yeah that was the thing i mean dr peter
was asking is there any one class
that had no sentiment of this this
virtue signatory and politically right
yeah there was none yeah
entire course i think i took 126
credits total yeah not even one class
doesn't matter we were talking about
classic art and that's the thing
i literally thought okay i pushed it
last like the semester the call like the
art and music right
so i thought this is going to be the
least politically correct class i can
take
and then it begins with who has problem
with
calling this course the western
civilization muse of art and music
and everyone's raising their hands
because like why do you have to learning
about this better than mozart the bigots
and all the people like you know
everything ruined by white men
yeah and it's even music even these
paintings
and as i i didn't raise my hand
everyone's looking at me
how do you not have a problem with us
like you used to hate us you're asian
you're so i think that's the thing is i
think the
problems way deeper than what people
think and it's
it's so that's what i when i learned
it's like
it's not that safe in america we can go
complete to the south
and looking at even europe that is like
i used to be way more optimistic like
you know that but now
i actually see wow this country can go
to south
and we might if u.s force land right
this is the only country
left to battle with the common spot in
china
we may lose the opportunity to be free
ever again as a humanity
wow so i mean that puts a lot of value
on having these kinds of conversations
it is i mean i'm troubled i'm troubled
by a lot of things but like censorship
on youtube for example
yeah it was very annoying to have to
listen to donald trump all the time
like just like create drama like the
news cycle was completely drowned out by
donald trump
but like banning him from twitter it was
like
that i that was that was scary for me
because
it's like that's a step towards the
direction where
you're going to like where's that take
us you're going to silence
people then it's like jordan peterson is
next that's why we need to promote
freedom of thinking
and speech right and one thing that i
love about dr peterson is
humans he's psychologists right he talks
about we
we we think by talking yeah
that's why when you go to therapy you
talk and then you hear yourself and then
you think and you come up to the
answer it's so important for humans to
talk
so we can think so when they say you
cannot talk means you cannot think
and they don't know the consequences of
that and this is why
i promote i want the freedom of speech
even though it hurts
ridiculous you know sometimes it can
it can be dangerous but the price the
alternative is so bad
that we should take the you know make
this trade-off everything has a
trade-off in this world
and it comes with a sacrifice right so i
think that's uh
that's what i want to see in america but
it's unfortunately like
the people like you say who decides what
is hate speech what is dangerous
that's what what i've been getting
scared because
everybody's imperfect yeah how do you
want to give the power to them and
they're going to decide
today they might agree with me say okay
your speech is good
promo is good and then they might come
back next year so you're probably
bad what are you gonna do when that
happens to you
we have to almost like get ideas out and
then play with them
i think what's a really important
component of that is forgiving each
other for
like realizing the word different person
day by day and certainly years later
and i think some of that is both
cultural mechanisms of saying like we
forgive
each other for wrong ideas or not wrong
ideas but
for who we are the the full evolution of
the human being
for the steps we've taken on that
evolution and
also creating mechanisms that
allow you to um allow
us to forgive each other like for
example on a twitter is like horrible
with this because
one of the main viral ways that people
create drama on twitter is like
pulling up an old tweet that somebody
said right
and then saying oh this is the guy that
thinks that yeah
and but that's like the opposite of the
mechanisms we need
to forgive ourselves forgive each other
for the things we've said in the past
um so part of that is the cultural part
of this is as
is the um the technological um
mechanisms you mentioned uh jordan
jordan peterson you had a great
conversation with him
what uh what was chatting with him like
i'm just i'm just curious because he's
deeply passionate especially on the
soviet union side
about the atrocities of these kinds of
systems what was it like
what did you um what did you agree with
him on
what did you disagree what were some
things you both kind of learned from
each other through that conversation do
you think
so here so my story the jordan period is
not a
very long one so one day i was walking
down in chicago
and they were like a huge theater or
sold out
he said big letter jordan peterson saw
that yeah
and then it was a huge theory in the
middle of chicago right like
doesn't like comedian like who can be
selling this entire thing out
at like 7 00 p.m and then with
my like ex-husband we were walking the
street
and then we saw people were like selling
those like tickets
like and for a very higher price right
and then you want to take it and then he
was like yeah sure
and we went in it's packed
and then i was just
give birth or like but i wasn't able to
understand his english that much my
english was served
and he didn't know who he was really no
no you were just curious
yeah he was like 2 000. he's the guy
that sells out of
a theater yeah yes i i saw dave rubin
came up before him and make jokes i
still
don't know who dave rubin is afterwards
i met them all but back then i had no
clue what that is
and then he was giving lessons but what
i got from that night was not
what jordan said but what people did on
the audience
these people like i don't know thousands
of people in this big theater
crying like babies and that's what i was
like
whatever that guy is doing is very
special right he was like making any
jokes he had no slides just
one simple person standing in the huge
dragon theater talk
and long time too and people cry
i was like wow okay mate whatever that
is i gotta check it out
and then i got home and then later many
years later i got a book
and i was start reading his book and it
talks about it explains so much right
like now
at columbia learn like everything gender
is like made of concept
construct like the higher kills my men's
idea make the hierarchy
and he begins with the number one the
the lobsters
had the hierarchies evolution of history
that is within
us that we want a higher key rate and
then
chapter five about socialization of
child
you know how do you raise them and all
of it and then
what's why telling the truth is matters
right
and there's a white like in it's
entire twelve lessons i read it and i
was like i'm
i was so grateful that i'm alive with
this like there's people always say
if socrates is alive how much would you
pay to have lunch with him
that kind of thing right so for me was
like okay
i'm like alive in the same contemporary
world one of the greatest singers of
my entire generation and then like
how much money you hang out with exactly
right how much money would i pay right
no no limit amount yeah and
i like reached out to michaela on her
pockets on twitter and connected and
then one day she'll say
do you wanna go my father's podcast i
was like
what i was like of course and
i was very nervous but i didn't expect
him to be
like that connected yeah because
i thought he was psychologists like he
saw so much suffering in the world he
started solving
his hobbies collecting those things to
remind him of the suffering of a human
being
so sometimes some people hear so much
atrocity they become like
very you know not engaged desensitized
he felt
he was feeling he was it's almost like
he was living through the experiences
with you as you were talking about it it
was an amazing conversation
so jordan is one of the great thinkers
of our time but i would say the greatest
thinkers of our time is michael malus
you've also got to just talk to uh
well so he wrote a book on north korea
yeah
it's an interesting style book i learned
a lot from it
i learned a lot from michael about it
and it's interesting that he chose
north korea as a as a thing to study
that he of all people this fascinating
human being that is michael
chose this darkest of aspects of
of uh humanity to study what uh
what do you think of michael what do you
think of his book on north korea called
dear reader that people should
definitely check out
absolutely so back then when i reached
michael through mutual friends south
korea i my english
wasn't good so i got a copy in my hand
i tried to read and a lot of them i
didn't understand
so but i thought it was very fascinating
how he
explained north korea through the deal
leaders perspective
right as nobody has ever done that and
you can reverse so much about the
state and the absurdity of entire
situation
and also through humor and that's what's
amazing about my chris is
he knows the full gravity of tragedy
he knows the first offering he's not
just like people here in america
on the bus feed making fun of kim jones
haircut they don't care what people go
through
michael cares deeply cares and then he
still does ridiculous jokes
so that that kind of reveals in a dark
way the absurdity
yeah of evil yeah he does that
masterfully do you
he's a genius he is definitely all right
let's
let's if he watches this uh
you know let's not get make his head too
big here
but is there some aspect to
i mean there is an absurdity to the
whole thing yeah uh
kim jong-un is this i mean he's almost
like a caricature of evil
like joke it's a joke a lot of people
think it's a joke
they just think like this is too too
absurd that is a they laugh
like can you imagine you laugh at
holocaust this is that
ridiculous can you maybe psychoanalyze
that a little bit
because that that's where my mind goes
too
like he's so ridiculous
that you can't it's almost like hard to
believe this is real
yeah is that just is that just my kind
of and people's desire to escape the
cruelty
of reality by just kind of making a joke
out of it
i think it is a few things right like
um to north korea as a nation
uh number one or number two smartest iq
people in the world
despite their magnitude so
so so there is i mean that that was
that's an interesting point so
in your sense the people are not dumb
still carry the the the brilliance
there's a there's a culture there
that's like hungry to become realized
like the people that that were like that
that are silenced by the electricity by
the
actually having no food all those kinds
of things like if you add the
electricity if you add the food you're
going to have a cultural center of the
world
like south korea that's what they
exactly did right the exact same career
one became one like 11th largest economy
one became the world's most like polish
nation right
and this is a perfect example like if i
don't know if you read that book
why nation affairs the system
it's not about the culture it's not
about people it's not about iq
what makes us too different is a system
south korea is north korea is a perfect
example of that
one is exact same capability we were
homogeneous
like country same language tradition all
of that
we gave them different system one is
free democracy one dictatorship
and came up with the biggest different
results
and i think north korea reveres that to
us
it's not because we are great that we
are living in this prosperity
free market the ideas gave us to this
the system we built our ancestors spirit
gave us this privilege it's not us
nothing is about us being special here
right the system that we have is quite
special
and north korea proves that to us it
doesn't matter even if you're smart
it that's all irrelevant and i think
that's why
people just keep denying that they want
to feel special like because
i'm awesome i got all of this like no
it's not you you got this
and when people say like i hate
capitalism it's like
without capitalism how do you came up
with this thing
literally how did you come up with this
the
systems matter and they matter
like um way more than
this individualistic society would like
to imagine
it is the most important thing you can
have in life choosing the right system
do you have a device for young people
today
you've lived an incredible life and you
have
i hope an incredible life ahead of you
what advice would you give to young
people today high schoolers
college students how to um
be successful in their career maybe
successful in life
last thing i want them to fear is guilty
it's it doesn't do anything right
so i hate when people talk about white
gears
it's like that doesn't make even any
sense right
i think the fact that they born with
freedom
is a blessing for all of us
it's not like i want them to want to do
something because they are guilty
i want them to do something because they
are grateful
it is true like we are sitting here the
fact why i have children is suffering
having kids you don't sleep costly like
so much
work like any like logical rational mind
you should never want children right
like why would you do that to yourself
especially as a woman right yeah you
don't want to do that to yourself
but think think about like we are
sitting here today
two of us in this amazing technology
this country
because somebody in savannah hundreds
thousands of years ago
they're hunting berries and surviving
cold
every suffering they can imagine they
fall for us
that's how we ended up here so life
is ultimately bigger than us
and i think that's what i want them it's
not like i want them to do the right
thing and be the best
person of themselves it's like i want
them to feel grateful
and we should be very grateful for the
freedom and then take full and
advantage of that i mean it starts with
the freedom to experience
everything in life and for your life
literally like
how my father like
you know working dying is a lot easier
than living
that takes like few minutes right
maximum
and living takes forever so when i was
facing this
unbelievable challenge i thought okay
this most rational thing i can do is
killing myself right now
but the hardest thing i can choose is
choose to live
and my father did that even in the
consumption camp even no matter what he
said
life is a gift you need to fight for it
and i think that's what's missing here
that we don't think life as a gift it's
a gift
like how many people had to fight for me
to be here today
think about the sacrifice they made for
many many many generations i don't even
know what they went through i can't even
fathom what they
went through they fought for life yeah
and that is my responsibility enough so
it doesn't make them
their fault fire was not meaningless
right it meant
something because now i'm carrying on
that fight
you mentioned considering suicide
do you think about your mortality now
now that you're perhaps in slightly
more comfortable place you still think
about
death i do because i
was informed actually when i was 21 that
i was on the killing list of kim jong-un
in by south korean intelligence and then
and then i i had to live with that right
but now i actually feel more because i
don't know you
follow jamal khashoggi's story the saudi
journalist
who got chopped off in turkey canvas
right
his reason why he got killed was he
became very prominent on twitter
he had a huge voice and saudis followed
him
now i became very first north korean to
have this many social media followings
and recently north korea started
invasion investigation team to
analyze whatever i do even though it's
first time for them
so they don't even know what at this
point like they're like this is so new
what do we do with kim jong-nam
kim jong-nam the half-brother kim
jong-un got killed in malaysia
that is another tragedy that i feel so
sorry for the u.s government is that
kim jong-nam was giving information to
the cia for the past like 10 years
that trip when he got killed in
malaysian airport he was meeting up with
the cia agent for two days on the
northern ireland
cia could have protected them they
didn't they let him die
and who killed them north korean kim
jong-un
do you know the malaysian the ladies are
the vx the nerve agent
north koreans kill them in malaysia in
the international land
so i mean jamal khashoggi who was a
youth resident
and the washington post journalist when
he got killed in saudi like a lamb
they chopped them into pieces in that
most
inhumane death what was the consequences
for the saudis
nothing the word is we think we living
in justice
country now there's no justice there is
no accountability for killing any decent
no matter how big their names are so you
don't think
you're vast and quickly growing social
media presence
protects you no it does opposite
because kim jong-un in german i spoke
out i don't know if you went through it
they
did everything they could to
characterize assassinate me
saying i'm a liar i'm a cia spy i get
paid
and then they reach out to penguin
saying we're gonna blow up
you cannot write this book and they did
it with the sony they hacked the sony
studio for making that stupid movie
interview right
and then penguin did their investigation
they met
every survivor that i went through in
the desert they got the voice recording
of them
because they don't want them to change
their mind later right people remember
differently
so they got the voice recordings like
the penguin regarding got the old
audience
and now we are ready for the lawsuit we
are going to publish this book
because we checked to verify every
single thing that was going in the book
and north korea couldn't do anything
anymore but that's a character
assassination
which by the way that's a whole nother
conversation that you were able to
survive that
i appreciate the kind of strength it
requires to survive that because you
don't know
and your character being assassinated is
in some ways
can be as painful as actual
assassination it's
worse everybody thinks you're a liar
yeah like everybody thinks
you're a liar yeah and now everybody
like you said this
nature of internet that as long as
something is written internet they think
that's a fact
yeah any stupid person can start a blog
and write about you
but they think oh because it's written
on the internet it's a legit
especially negative stuff that's the
thing i was kind of trying to
elaborate on there's a viral aspect to
calling somebody a fraud or a liar yeah
that
nobody questions whether it's true or
not it just spreads yeah it's a
it's a dark side of our human nature
that we want to destroy
yeah the people who are rising yeah
we cannot stand it yeah yeah we any
change maker in this world who wasn't
controversial right martial
engineer like nurse mandela he was
called as a terrorist
right so i just did not know
i the character assassination is the
thing it'll probably
continue with you it will continue
forever so you have to get stronger and
stronger i think in the face of that
but actual assassination and perhaps
it's me being hopeful because
i have a situation with russia that i
hope i'm not under
well i don't care actually but there's
some aspect in which social media
presence i thought protects you a little
bit
because just imagine the outrage
from an attempted assassination
assassination of you
but what was our wage when drama koshki
got killed like that
was the social media presence large over
one million people i don't have that
family
he was 1.6 million twitter followers
and the outrage wasn't there no because
saudis
spoke to amazon the prime studio netflix
there were people made a documentary
about him but told everybody don't
cannot get that deal so there was a huge
censorship on that
and people of course like i mean they
can talk about it one day
some distance from saudi got killed yeah
horrible it just dissipates like they
they move on to the next cute puppy
right they didn't execute cat like
that's what the nature of this
new generation does they desensitized it
doesn't affect them they
keep following the instant pleasure
instant high
that's what instagram does to you it
changes your brain
like that's why i always reminisce about
the shallows we became shallow and
shallow
and our brain changes permanently so
this inner generation we can get them
angry for like 10 minutes
create hashtags for one day but then as
quick as that was
it goes down like instantly and i think
that's the
well that means that okay so that means
that there is uh
it's an effective way to get rid of
opposition is by murdering them
and that means a united states if it
stands for freedom if it stands for
the freedom of exchange of ideas should
be protecting
people like you but they because they
don't want to be involved
they will they they they didn't even
protect kim jong-nam who was giving
information 10 years to risk in his life
that's what is so i mean working for cia
is not bad
i'm not i don't i hope i mean the thing
is
he was giving information to bring down
the vision yeah that is valuable that is
something noble about him
but then you just don't go extra miles
to that
that's when i lost my faith in the u.s
system as well like this country
just cares about saving face what is
most
minimum because they pay for anything
and like i went up south korea
constantly every single day intelligence
calling me
like the north korean agent going this
place where are you going
the u.s citizens came to us nobody
they said when people said that you're a
cia agent like i wish they called me
i really truly do but nobody nobody does
here
i'm sure they know what's going on but
the south korean agent is more like
oh my gosh we don't want you to get
killed a south korean citizen right
yeah and now i'm trying to become a
citizen
so it's in a way it's i don't know
what's worse
are you are you afraid for your life
i was afraid for those ever three four
years i was afraid and it was
but i had to came terms with it like in
my enemy
is not on some crazy psychopath it's a
state
with a new career power to attack the
most powerful country
if kim jong-un decides if i die i'm
gonna die
it's not up to me right so in a way it's
just
liberating that you it's like if you are
like afraid of some mobs or some like
gangsters on the street
it's almost like you have power over a
little bit you gotta be like thinking
that's my fault i
i went that way right but when it comes
to kim jong-un
i know like my enemy is so much bigger
than me
it's in always a liberation and also it
always
i just i live a lot so i have seen a lot
i've seen everything
i don't have that much yogurt left here
like okay i'm going too soon you know
it's like okay
maybe it's time like death is a part of
life
so in some sense you're willing to
accept death
to keep fighting for freedom in your
in at least in part a place you call
home yeah
it is do you hope that one day you can
return to north korea
i hope so i hope i bring my son and tell
him this
is like where your ancestors from too
it would look very different than the
place you came from
in your as you hope
do you do you hope that there's a
democracy one day
that north korea looks like south korea
well that'll be in paradise right
that's but i'm a rational optimist
i'm not like just optimistic because i
have to be
i think as long as there are people who
have changed the world right
like who believed in something and
worked for it
and like i don't know like there's a
like alice she wrote a few people
holding entirely this word
right i really believe in that i think
as long as that continues that can
happen in my country
as long as people like you someday you
want to decide to do something about
north korean working for
using your brain power to solve this
puzzle how fascinating would that be
that's why i
continue to speak continue to recruit
to inspire millions to do something
the books you like are all the books i
love so
i have to mention this you mentioned uh
briefly on the uh
with jordan uh siddhartha by herman
hesse
is uh it's an incredible book yeah
they're
i mean i don't i don't know exactly what
i want to ask here but there's some
i think the book kind of
through telling a story yeah reveals
that
life is suffering and yet there's beauty
in it the beauty in
every moment it uses kind of a river
painted metaphor is there is there um
is there something that you could say
speak to like how that book
impacted your life and the way you live
life maybe the way you
see life whether it's on the life of
suffering side or that
life is beautiful side i mean he goes
the entire journey right
he goes in this state like i'm so
enlightened that i cannot
deal with people they're in love and cry
about it
right they're like that's so like
primitive
once he has his own son he actually
being attached
he actually cares he actually really
does whole thing
right that's the thing that he used to
think not once his son comes find him
he looks at life differently i think
that's the thing i did have the kind of
journey where
oh nothing matters right so bitter so
so like so cynical and
after i met so many incred incredible
people i was talking about that
person who told me he was gay he told me
i love you and i was like why do you
love me
in the past people when they wanted me
was because they want to rape me
everybody wanted something for me that's
why they wanted me
and i never understood you can love
somebody unconditionally
and this gay guy the last one was going
to sleep with me right
and he loves me and i think
i had a blessing after my journey
meeting people who
loved me unconditionally because i was
just being a human
and i think that's what it is now for me
that like him
i live for love now i live for love any
kind of love love for knowledge
i like i read so many books because i
love books right
i love what i do i love my people i love
humanity
you know even it sometimes annoys me
i love myself and that's beautiful too
the annoying parts are beautiful too
what do you let me ask the ridiculous
question what do you think is the
meaning of this whole thing
of uh what's the meaning of life
well i think at this point i stop
questioning why i'm here
right like it doesn't matter someone put
the atom there or the big bang
i'm here that's truth right i'm going to
accept that fully
so what instead of me keep asking the
impossible question what i'm here
i'm going to let you do that science do
that right
you guys go out in the space and look
for the evidence i'm contested
you accept that you're here and you're
just going to
enjoy like you're here for love as you
said
that's the thing i think i'm here for
the
process of pursuing something bigger
than me process of doing something
it's not like a model it's not a virtual
signal or anything it just makes me
happy that i fight for something bigger
like that me right so how boring is it
every day you get up like oh my god i'm
gonna buy myself
this so i'm gonna get this for myself
it's so boring isn't it
so in a way i think that's what it is i
i'm grateful
that i'm in a state i don't have to fly
for myself anymore
but many people have to do that and
that's sometimes more than enough they
have to do and i salute them they are
doing
fighting saving themselves every day but
now i'm
i'm not there i'm very blessed that's
why i'm very grateful
so fighting for something much bigger
than you but do you still believe
that you can change the world that you
can be a thing that
at least in part helps north korea or
even broader helps alleviate
some suffering in the world so that's
the thing uh i was reading this book
food
by randomness right yeah
i was like they're up here like oh my
god you're so courageous you're amazing
i was like you know i'm not i'm horrible
right i know myself you don't want to
tell me that
it's random why i end up here like why
did i pick up english so quickly why do
i love books right
i don't know why yeah it's random don't
ask why
just enjoy it yes it's random i think i
don't know how
the history will remember me i think
only thing i have to at this point to
make sure is that the people
after constructing a lot of security
teams like now north korea
became less smarter like you said they
may be more disguised as a like a
suicide
and a car accident yeah so when i die
they don't even know i got killed
yeah i think that's a higher chance so
i think that's the thing like people are
suffering take it or not it's
your choice and at least it's my
responsibility for them to know what's
going on
i think if you did not know and didn't
do anything you are not even guilty of a
thing
but once you know then you are not doing
it then you
something is like not right so that's
what i'm doing like
i want the people to know and then
what they are gonna do is not my my
problem afterwards right
so my role is very small in that regards
and
i just hope that would
humanize north koreans for the first
time because we have been so dehumanized
right like we are like looking like
robots if you look at us marching and
cry like
when dear later dies it almost seems
like you don't even have the same
emotions people cannot connect us
in the same level and i think that's
something is uh we that's something
media have done it to us and you're
you're shining a small light on this
dark part of the world that i think
and you make it you're so modest but i
think
i think you will have that little light
uh just might be a big thing that
changes
that incredible amount of suffering
that's happening on that part of the
world
you know me you're you're an amazing
person
i'm so fortunate i get a chance to talk
with you i can't wait what you do in the
future
you're i hope you write many more books
i i do
hope you uh continue making videos
continue having conversations you're an
inspiration to me and
millions of others i really appreciate
you talking with me today
i'm so honored thank you thank you
thank you for listening to this
conversation with you on me park and
thank you to
valcampo the gala games better help
and eight sleep check them out in the
description to support this podcast
and now let me leave you some words from
bob marley
better to die fighting for freedom and
be a prisoner
all the days of your life thank you for
listening
and hope to see you next time